todos los días se recibe la visita del
papa- francisco rafael coordina todos
los detalles para su recibimiento en la
catedral saint joseph de bagdad
grandi scan en forma el viene por todos
los iraquíes no solo por los cristianos
eso también es sectarismo pensar que él
viene solo por los cristianos
[Música]
los caldeos hacen parte de la iglesia de
oriente y son la rama del cristianismo
más extendida en irak donde actualmente
habitan alrededor de 500 mil
practicantes de esta fe
más de un millón han abandonado el país
desde que fuera derrocado sadam husein
en 2003 y los conflictos posteriores
incluido el avance del estado islámico
en 2014
ellos no confían en el futuro creo que
ese es un problema psicológico de next
disco que viene luego porque antes del
issys estaba al qaeda y otras milicias
y ahora hay otras milicias que son más
poderosas que el gobierno de irak
christchurch estas dos son ácidos que
conservan su lengua el arameo y son
habitantes originales de esta región del
mundo a pesar de que no siempre se les
ha reconocido así ahora nuestra
existencia durante sadam husein no fue
mejor incluso fue peor hoy tenemos esta
libertad para hablar escritos de la
historia del cristianismo y dídac se
remite a los orígenes de esta fe y su
huella está en muchos rincones de bagdad
este hospital san rafael de los
dominicos es una institución en la
ciudad
a pesar de las circunstancias y su salud
el pontífice ha querido venir para
darnos coraje y para ayudarnos a aferrar
a nuestra tierra y religión
la visita del papa es interpretada como
un gesto de apoyo para los cristianos
iraquíes pero también con un mensaje de
esperanza para crear diferentes etnias y
religiones que encuentren un camino para
vivir en paz